les chiffres un jour et qu'on revienne
sur cette séquence émotion et admiration
ça s'est passé chez jean luc reichmann
c'était dimanche midi et tout le monde a
parlé de cette jeune fille qui s'appelle
camille regarder l regardez cet extrait
fait je suis atteint d'un cancer
oui qui s'est généralisé donc je suis
sous chimiothérapie d'accord et voilà ça
suit son cours et j'apprends à profiter
de la vie
moi j'ai pas d'espoir de guérison
possible donc la chimiothérapie elle est
faite pour me maintenir le plus
longtemps donc quand on sait ça raids
ont profité de tous les instants
possible alors moi je voulais juste vous
prendre dans mes bras
parce que si toutefois je peux vous
apporter des réponses nous apporter
c'est ta vie tu es magnifique la nuque
et marié qu'à une licence en psychologie
elle a été invitée donc dans les 12
coups de midi avec jean luc reichmann
elle s'est confiée donc sur sa maladie
comme vous pouvez le voir et j'ai eu un
garçon qui s'appelle damien mercereau
qui est journaliste au figaro
aujourd'hui qui me dit cyril j'ai fait
des interviews de camille et elle a un
truc en particulier qui la fait sourire
c'est ta gueule voilà et elles n'ont
aucune émission de tpm paix de balances
ton poste ou de la grande barca je vous
dis allez atteinte d'un cancer de
l'estomac
à 8 ans elle récidive dix ans plus tard
peut être 17 ans à 10 ans puis à 17 ans
aujourd'hui son concert s'est
généralisée et camille grâce à damien on
a réussi à la faire venir aujourd'hui et
réaliser sont restés droit camille est
avec nous je la rencontre en main tendue
[Applaudissements]
je
magnifique bien la cam marc planus est
là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
heureusement comme en foot le voir ce
que j'ai été très touché parce qu'on a
vu dimanche
et voilà je t'ai trouvé voilà je trouve
que ton message il est incroyable voilà
je trouve que ta joie de vivre
voilà elle m'a transporté dimanche c'est
vrai que jean lui qui a été formidable
c'est avec toi fais et je voudrais dire
voilà demain qu'est ce que tu fais
demain j'ai rien de prévu n'a rien prévu
alors j'ai envie de faire une surprise
parce que je sais que tu as un rêve ce
serait aussi de faire une émission
autour de la table que tpm paix et bien
demain est-ce que tu acceptes d'être
avec nous toutes les missions et de
d'être faire partie des chroniqueurs de
touche pas à mon poste
[Applaudissements]
ok
demain ce sera avec nous donc on va bien
s'occuper de toi tu vas être avec tout
le monde en coulisses voilà tu es et tu
feras en fait mieux avec nous on va
faire bosser tous a dit chen bin a mon
avis tu ne pourras pas moins beau c'est
que les autres et voilà je voulais vous
dire donc c'est votre nouvelle merci et
u13 heureux pour toi merci donc demain
tu seras avec messi seulement voilà
[Applaudissements]